♪
TREY: THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US, I AM TREY GOWDY, IT'S
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
FBI BELIEVES THERE IS
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
CHARGE HUNTER BIDEN WITH
VIOLATIONS OF TAX, AND GUN
STATUTES ACCORDS TO MEDIA
REPORTS FBI DOESN'T MAKE
CHARGES DECISIONS.
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS DO.
SO THE MATTER NOW SITS WITH
U.S. ATTORNEY IN DELAWARE.
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAWYERS HAVE
ASKED FOR A CHANCE TO
PRESENTS INFORMATION BEFORE
FINAL CHARGING DECISION IS
MADE, AND UNDER
INVESTIGATION SINCE
2018, MOST IN MEDIA EITHER
BURIED THAT STORY OR CLAIMED
IT WAS RUSHED
DISINFORMATION.
-- OR IT WAS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, TWO THINGS
WORTH NOTING AGENTS,
PROSECUTORS MEMBERS OF GRAND
JURY TAKE AN OATH NOT TO
LEAK INFORMATION, SOMEONE
VIOLATED THAT OATH.
LEAKS IN PAST HAVE HURT
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS,
BUT MAINLY THE LEAKS HURT A
JUSTICE SYSTEM, IN NEED OF A
REASON TO RESPECT IT.
SECONDLY, THIS MARKS 1,000
TH TIME ADAM SCHIFF HAS BEEN
WRONG ABOUT SOMETHING, HE
TOLD YOU THIS WAS ALL
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION, HOW
DO YOU THINK THAT DC MEDIA
WOULD TREAT A REPUBLICAN
MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHO IS
WRONG AS MUCH AS ADAM SCHIFF
IS?
>> JOINING US NOW FORMER
UNITED STATES ATTORNEY FROM
GREAT STATE OF TEXAS,
CONGRESSMAN FROM TEXAS,
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JOHN LEE
RADCLIFFE.
THIS DID NOT TURN OUT TO BE
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION, DID
IT?
>> WELL, YOU CORRECTLY
POINTED UT THIS IS A TWO
YEAR ANNIVERSARY THIS WEEK
OF AN EFFORT BY DEMOCRATIC
CHAIRMAN OF HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE TO
CREATE A LIE THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT MAY RESULT
IN CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHER
MEMBERS OFFED BIDEN FAMILY
WAS RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
THAT LIE WAS PERPETUATED BY
51 INTELLIGENCE FORMER
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
MOSTLY DEMOCRATIC APPOINTEES
FROM OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
THEN AMPLIFIED BY SOCIAL
MEDIA FLAT FORMS AND
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THAT TOOK
PLACE TOO MISLEAD AND
MISREPRESENT TO AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHO WAS HAPPENING AND
PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE, TWO
YEARS AGO THIS WEEK.
THAT I WAS HAVING CONHERRING
AS WITH BILL BARR, ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY ABOUT NEED
TO PUT OUT PUBLIC STATEMENTS
TO NOT COUNTER WHO CHINA WAS
DOING OR RUSSIA OR IRAN WAS
DOING TO MEDDLE IN THE 2020
ELECTION.
TREY: YOU AND I COULD NOT
GET AWAY WITH WHAT HE HAS
GOTTEN AWAY WITH, YOU WERE
ONCE YOU U.S. ATTORNEY IN
GREAT STATE OF TEXAS.
LET VIEWERS KNOW, IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT PROSECUTORS WILL
GO FORWARD, WHAT DO YOU
THINK THAT U.S. ATTORNEY IS
EVALUATING RIGHT
NOW.
>> IF THE LEAKS ARE ACCURATE
AND U.S. ATTORNEY IS
EVALUATES TAX FRAUD CHARGES,
IF U.S. ATTORNEY HAS THEM,
THEY HAVE ALREADY BEEN
REVIEWED AND
APPROVED TWICE IN DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE IF THEY ARE
FOLLOWING PROTOCOL, THEY
HAVE TO START REVIEW WITH
IRS DISTRICT COUNCIL, THEN
THE DOJ CRIMINAL TAX
DIVISION HAS TO GREEN LIGHT
IT BEFORE IT GETS TO U.S.
ATTORNEY.
IF THE U.S. ATTORNEY IN
DELAWARE IS LOOKING AT THIS,
THIS IS LITTLE DOUBT THERE
IS SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO OF
PROBABLE CAUSE TO CHARGE
HUNTER BIDEN WITH TAX FRAUD.
THAT IS HE RECEIVED INCOME
HE DIDN'T DECLARE ON TAXES.
MY GUESS IS THEY ARE
EVALUATING
HUNTER BIDEN'S DEFENSE,
SAYING, YEAH I DID IT BUT I
WAS AN ALCOHOLIC OR A
DRUNK AT THE
TIME, I AM SURPRISED THAT
TWO YEARS AFTER HAVING
CORROBORATING INFORMATION IN
A LAPTOP AND CORROBORATING
WITNESSES TALKING ABOUT
FOREIGN AGENT
REGISTRATION VIOLATIONS,
THAT THE LEAKS ARE NOT ABOUT
THOSE TYPES OF CHARGES, I
WOULD HAVE EXPECTED THAT
AT-THIS-POINT.
TREY: I HOPE HIS DEFENSE IS
BETTER THAN I WAS DRUNK AND
HIGH, UNLESS THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED, I DON'T THINK
VOLUNTARY
INTOXICATION IS MUCH OF A
DEFENSE.
>> AND NOW NORTH KOREA IS
ACTING BADLY AGAIN, BREAK
MAKING THREATS, WHAT SHOULD
YOUR VIEWERS?
SHOULD THEY BE WORRIED OR
SAY JUST THE CRAZE ROCKET
MAN?
>> YOU SEE NORTH KOREA DOING
UNPRECEDENTEDDED THINGS THEY
HAVE NOT DONE IN A LANGUAGE
PERIOD OF TIME -- LONG
PERIOD OF TIME, TWO WEEKS
AGO THEY FIRED BALLISTIC
MISSILE OVER JAPAN, AND NOW
THERE ARE REPORTS THAT NORTH
KOREA MAY BE PREPARING TO
TEST NUCLEAR WEAPONS FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN OVER 5 YEARS.
YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK IT IS
A COINCIDENCE THEY ARE
HAPPENING NOW WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS
REWARDED ESCALATORY AND
PROVOCATIVE BEHAVIOR.
WHEN RAN STARTED RATTLING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS SABRE, THEY
GOT OFFERED A TRILLION
DOLLAR SANCTIONS RELIEF
DEAL, AND KIM JONG-UN IN
NORTH KOREA WANTS SANCTIONS
RELIEF AND A PIECE OF THE
ACTION, HE UNDERSTANDS THAT
ADMINISTRATION, SOMETIMES
THIS BAD
BEHAVIOR IS REWARDED.
TREY: ANOTHER ALLEGATION
AGAINST HUNTER BIDEN
INVOLVES MAKING FALSE
STATEMENT IN APPLICATION FOR
A FIREARM, LET'S WALK DOWN
MEMORY LANE, DO YOU RECALL
WHAT MEDIA AND MUELLER'S
PROSECUTORS GOT ANIMATED GO
FALSE STATEMENTS, THEY COULD
NOT THINK OF A PRISON
SENTENCE LONG ENOUGH FOR
SOMEONE WHO MADE FALSE
STATIONS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT WILL BE
THE SAME REACTION?
>> THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT EVEN-HANDED
APPLICATION OF JUSTICE,
FOLKS WILL RECALL ROGER
STONE PROSECUTORS WANTED 7
YEARS FOR LIE ING TO
CONGRESS, WHEN BILL BARR
REDUCES IT TO 40 MONTHS
PEOPLE CALLED FOR HISS RIC,
CONTRAST THAT WITH TRUMP
HATING FBI DIRECTOR DIRECTOR
ANDY McCABE WHO LIED TO
CONGRESS 4 TIMES UNDER OATH,
HIS PUNISHMENT WAS TO GET
FIRED FROM THE FBI AND
SENTENCED TO WORK FOR LOW
RATING CNN.
IF HUNTER BIDEN IS CHARGED
WITH FALSE STATEMENTS AND
EITHER CONVICTED OR PLEADS
GUILTY, IT WILL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND OTHERS
APPROACH THIS YOU KNOW THE
EVEN-HANDED APPLICATION LAW
FROM BOB MUELLER AND OTHERS
SAYS THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
OFFENSE.
TREY: IF WE COULD WORK
AROUND YOUR GOLF SCHEDULE, I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING YOU
BACK OMPLE THANK YOU FOR
JOINING U